tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel maria
callas est décédé cet après midi à paris
victime d'une crise cardiaque
valéry giscard d'estaing devant les
avocats le rapport peyrefitte sur la
violence sera concrétisée par des textes
avant la fin de l'année
raymond barre a refusé de parler de
politique française devant la presse
américaine pré retraite à 60 ans des
pensions trop faible et la peur de
l'ennui freine les salariés intéressés
l'essence à base de foin ça existe
jean-paul la rivière a rencontré son
inventeur bonsoir la rencontre robert
fabre georges marchais dans notre
émission spéciale l'événement hier soir
précédé des journaux d'information qui
hier et avant-hier vous ont fait
pratiquement vivre en direct à chaud la
crise dont le débat politique au sein de
la gauche ont constitué un ensemble
d'informations de première grandeur
rarement écrit un confrère les français
auront été ainsi associé à un événement
politique en cours de déroulement
c'était la première fois en effet qu'on
débattait aussi longtemps et
publiquement entre partenaires de la
gauche sur des points de divergence est
essentielle
cette grande explication l'émotion qu'il
accompagnait parfois le tutoiement entre
robert et georges cela avait en effet
quelque chose d'une grande première
pourtant il n'en est rien sorti de
concret mais seulement dans l'immédiat
les radicaux de gauche ne reprendrons
pas la discussion pour l'instant des
contacts ont lieu et auront lieu sans
doute pendant tout le week-end robert
fabre est reparti dans l'aveyron à
villefranche françois mitterrand sera
dans la nièvre les conversations au
téléphone sont fréquentes en ce moment à
paris entre socialistes et communistes
par exemple il faudra attendre lundi
toutefois pour avoir de nouveaux
développements lundi c'est en quelque
sorte à une offensive du parti
socialiste que nous assisterons après la
publication dès demain à un million
d'exemplaires d'un texte en quatre pages
sur les propositions
socialiste pour l'actualisation du
programme commun et surtout le comité
directeur du parti se réunira et fera
des propositions concrètes susceptibles
je cite de recréer le climat nécessaire
pour un aboutissement positif de la
négociation j'ai extrait cela d'un
article de claude estier dans l'unité
qui décrit la crise en trois mots le
sommet manqué du 14 septembre restera
une date grise dans l'histoire de la
gauche à l'intransigeance du parti
communiste a répondu un refus des
radicaux de gauche de poursuivre la
discussion
le parti socialiste lui entend demeurer
sereins
pendant ce temps georges marchais
affirmait nous mettrons tout en oeuvre
avec le soutien des travailleurs pour
que la discussion reprennent sans
préalable et pour qu'elle aboutisse à un
accord sur un programme censure achètent
sans surenchère et sans rabais après
avoir précisé justement dans l'humanité
que les positions des radicaux de gauche
et du parti socialiste sont en retrait
sur celle du programme commun et puis
tout à l'heure le bureau politique du
parti communiste a annoncé qu'il était
prêt à faire les efforts nécessaires
pour aboutir dès lors que ses
partenaires observe la même attitude
robert fabre at il eu finalement raison
de claquer la porte
on attendait évidemment un sondage pour
savoir ce que l'opinion vous vous en
pensiez
il sera publié demain matin par le matin
de paris il a été réalisé hier et
aujourd'hui sur plus de 600 personnes
par l'institut harris et bien 47% des
personnes interrogées disent que robert
fabre a eu raison
37% des socialistes aussi et puis 11% de
communistes disent que robert fabre a eu
raison
après ce coup d'éclat qu'en est il des
chances de la gauche au législatif
répondent réponses du sondage 53% des
personnes interrogées
oui les chances de la gauche sont un peu
plus faibles voire beaucoup plus faible
voilà où nous en sommes ce soir une
bonne part de l'initiative semble
maintenant appartenir aux socialistes
l'un des responsables du parti louis
mermaz nous donne d'abord son opinion
sur le débat d'hier soir le débat entre
deux leaders de la gauche deux
tempéraments différents
à mon sens ça a été très intéressant car
il a permis de commencer à comprendre
les intentions des uns et des autres
robert fabre a dit ce qu'il ne voulait
pas georges marchais à poser des
questions mais également apporter des
réponses
j'ai trouvé très intéressant de
l'entendre dire je crois que c'était la
première fois qu'il le disait aussi
clairement que les nationalisations
supplémentaires qu'il propose comme
celle de peugeot citroën de la
sidérurgie sont négociables
c'est pour moi un fait positif est-ce
qu'il est pensable en toute dernière
extrémité que les socialistes reprennent
la discussion avec les communistes
seulement sans les radicaux de gauche
nous pensons nous que le problème est
maintenant de préparer dès la rentrée et
des radicaux de gauche les radicaux de
gauche sont une des familles qui
comptent pour l'union de la gauche il
faut donc qu'ils puissent à nouveau être
associés aux travaux
pour réussir cela il faut savoir ce que
nous allons faire nous avons le souci
nous de voir la gauche unie et nous ne
pouvons pas nous permettre un deuxième
échec il ne peut pas y avoir de deuxième
sortie donc il faut bien se comprendre
pour pouvoir se retrouver le plus vite
possible et les jours qui restent
doivent être utilisés à cela je voudrais
ajouter ici quelques phrases de pierre
mauroy le numéro deux du parti
socialiste dans son livre héritiers de
l'avenir qui viennent paraître et que
j'ai reçu aujourd'hui c'est un propos
qui explique peut-être pas mal de choses
sur ce qui se passe à gauche le parti
communiste est condamné à l'évolution
écrit pierre mauroy à cause du front
unique que la gauche est obligé de
maintenir face au régime giscardien à
cause d'une collaboration difficile mais
permanente entre nos deux partis car ni
permis au roi j'ai la conviction que le
parti socialiste par sa pratique d'unité
a joué un rôle dans l'évolution du pc
l'intégration du parti communiste à la
vie démocratique passe finalement par le
renforcement du parti socialiste
appelait ainsi à devoir assumer la
primauté au sein de la gauche voici ce
qu'écrit pierre mauroy à washington il
est fort probable bien qu'on ne sache
rien que jimmy carter et raymond barre
et parler de ses problèmes politiques
français mais ce qu'on retient pour
l'instant du séjour du premier ministre
en dehors d'un rapprochement des points
de vue sur la politique internationale
et 2
accueil extrêmement chaleureux que lui a
réservé des mii carter c'est le forcing
de raymond barre pour l'atterrissage de
concorde à new york
il en a parlé plusieurs fois au
président américain il en a parlé encore
ce matin au petit déjeuner qui lui a
permis de rencontrer des membres du
congrès il sera certainement amené en
parler en ce moment même un à la presse
américaine puisqu'il est l'hôte des
journalistes au national press club
rejoignons tout de suite gérard saint
paul notre envoyé spécial pour le film
de la journée
ministre raymond barre avait évité de
parler politique intérieure aux états
unis il avait laissé entendre qu'il
n'était pas venu pour ça et bien vous
venez de l'entendre et le tête à tête le
nouveau tête à tête de ce matin entre
raymond barre et le président américain
jimmy carter lui même qui a parlé de
cette situation de politique intérieure
en france et plus largement en europe
certes il l'a fait avec sa réserve
habituelle avancée mais tout de même il
a dit des choses puisque il a employé la
même expression que le président giscard
d'estaing en disant notamment qu'il
espérait que les français que les
européens puis largement serait le bon
choix
il espérait également a dit le président
carter que ces forces démocratiques qui
sont actuellement au pouvoir en europe
le resterai en empêchant ainsi les
communistes de prendre trop d'importance
voilà donc l'événement de la journée
pour ce voyage cette visite officielle
qui se poursuit à un rythme de croisière
que chacun juge excellents certes de
part et d'autre on est extrêmement franc
les positions ne coïncident pas toujours
loin de là
raymond barre dans son discours en
quatre points essentiels hier sur la
détente sur le nom protectionnisme entre
pays libre sur d'autres problèmes comme
le désarmement a été très clair cela ne
plaît pas toujours sans doute aux
américains mais enfin l'atmosphère est
bonne
le président américain aura donc
enregistrer tout ce que les français par
la voix du premier ministre raymond
barre sont venus lui dire c'est pour lui
il le dit à chaque occasion une sorte
d'informations supplémentaires sur les
problèmes politiques de l'europe qui
parfois peut-être lui échappent encore
un peu ce matin le premier ministre a eu
un petit déjeuner important avec des
sénateurs américains 11 parmi les plus
influents c'est important dans la mesure
le président jimmy carter recevra la
semaine prochaine
les membres du congrès qu'il entendra à
propos de concorde concorde c'est le
point clé tout de même de ce voyage là
dessus le président jimmy carter a redit
ce qu'il avait dit jusqu'à présent la
décision ne dépend pas de lui
encore que il laisse entendre qu'il est
favorable à l'atterrissage de concorde à
new york
la décision sera prise normalement sur
la base d'un dossier honnête a dit le
président américain
à partir du 24 septembre le dernier
exercice difficile pour le premier
ministre raymond barre
c'est le national press club en effet
raymond barre va devoir répondre aux
questions des journalistes américains et
se soumettre à un feu roulant de ces
questions là encore le premier ministre
trouvera sans doute une conclusion à ce
voyage que l'on peut qualifier d'ores et
déjà deux positifs tf1 la maison blanche
l'amélioration de notre commerce
extérieur sera plus difficile que prévu
oui depuis le début de l'année avec près
de 11 milliards de déficit commercial
la france a déjà dépassé les chiffres
envisagée pour l'ensemble de 77 par le
plan barre le mauvais résultat du mois
d'août que nous indiquions hier n'est
pas forcément significatif puisque
traditionnellement pendant les vacances
nous exportons moins cependant il ya des
signes inquiétants comme la poussée
rapide de nos importations de machines
et de biens de consommation
avec emmanuel de la taille le point sur
les difficultés de nos échanges avec
l'étranger
l'augmentation du déficit extérieur est
un revers même provisoire pour le plan
de redressement revers économique car
avec l'incertitude politique il peut
rendre à terme le franc plus fragiles
sur le marché des changes revers
politique aussi puisque le commerce avec
l'étranger et un des tests de réussite
du plan barre est une des armes pour
accuser la future politique de la gauche
de replonger la france dans la déroute
au delà des controverses électorale il
faut rappeler qu une balance équilibrée
et la principale contrainte qui pèse sur
n'importe quelle politique
en effet tout déficit davantage
d'importations que d'exportation a trois
conséquences redoutables un endettement
qui pèse sur l'avenir un ralentissement
des affaires de la production car
l'argent du déficit par à l'étranger et
une baisse du franc qui accélère
l'asphyxient de l'économie pour rétablir
l'équilibré le plan barre à comprimer
les salaires et les dépenses qui
améliorent les coûts de production
restent à la consommation et forcent à
exporter plus est importé moins cela a
amorcé le rééquilibrage
il reste cependant une faiblesse majeure
de la france à la moindre réaccélération
de l'économie les
importations grimpent deux fois plus
vite que les exportations et ramène au
déficit car nos entreprises résistent
mal à la concurrence
on retrouve là un des grands problèmes
du débat de la gauche où l'on mise à
linverse du plan barre sur une relance
des salaires et de la production
le ps et le pc sont conscients du danger
extérieur de leurs opérations et avance
des remèdes possibles
la vraie solution n'a encore été
expérimenté nulle part car depuis la
crise toute injection de pouvoir d'achat
s'est immédiatement dévorer partout dans
la rechute extérieur et les mini relance
de raymond barre but sur le même
obstacle
la pré retraite à 60 ans pour tous la
quitte
la question qui se pose est la suivante
où en est l'application de l'accord
national conclu le 13 juin dernier entre
le patronat et les syndicats pour
l'instant on peut sans doute parler d'un
mauvais départ
andré bergeron de force ouvrière
souligne l autre jour que seuls 127
salariés en bénéficient sur les 350
milles qui pourraient y prétendre
cependant aussi bien le ministre du
travail que le cnpf que la cgt explique
que sans doute les salariés n'ont pas
encore eu le temps de s'informer et de
prendre une décision qui tout de même
quitte même est grave vingt à vingt-cinq
mille personnes ont demandé des dossiers
d'information dans les services du
travail des préfectures
mais la décision et je voulais 10 est
importante et cela demande le temps de
la réflexion justement qu'elle est en ce
moment l'état d'esprit des salariés
concernés par cette pré retraite à 60
ans est bien françois go est allé leur
demander dans une entreprise qui emploie
200 salariés des critères d'attribution
pour la paix retraite à 60 ans par
conséquent des dispositions forcément
restrictive
il y en a exemple il faut avoir cotisé
au moins dix ans un régime de sécurité
sociale notamment au cours des cinq
années précédant la préretraite ou bien
encore ils ne font pas déjà bénéficié
comme les anciens prisonniers de guerre
d'un autre système de retraite à 60 ans
rien n'est simple est ce que ça vous
intéresse
pour quelles raisons les moyens
pétillent
ils sont oui voilà j'aurai pas les
moyens de suivre débit c'est à dire que
votre avis le montant actuel de la
retraite a suffisamment un wii rouge
ça m'intéresserait si j'étais si j'étais
sur la gère la pension pleine manqué
c'est ma 65 ans seront chères à temps et
si je l'apprends m'attend je perds un
pourcentage
quelque 30%
trop beau temps c'est parce que c'est le
trésor de zine et en plus de ça je suce
ma b
bouffer rachat alors
j'ai tout intérêt à rester jusqu'à 65
personnellement ça vous ennuierait vous
avez travaillé brutalement c'est une
dune d'adaptation morale qui ferait que
je fasse oui naturellement oui enfin je
me prépare quand même puisque la barre
64 ans le préfère quand même si
évidemment on est en 30 ans à paris
l'artisan je n'ai pas de retraite est
obligatoirement et bien si je pouvais
avoir une prolongation de mon travail ça
m'arrangerait bien par cycle pas
question
on m'a pas du tout non enfin du baiida
mans ça m'intéresse mais s'il y avait
des petits problèmes si j'ai encore
avant qui rendait l'armée qui poursuit
ses études en plus personnellement alors
j'ai une petite appréhension de
m'ennuyer mais qu'on voit là est tout de
même vous pensez en toute façon je
pensais d'apprendre évidemment je sens
bien qu'elle prend de l'âge effectif au
que laisser la place aux jeunes ça y est
pas en réalité le véritable bilan de
l'accord sur la pré retraite à 60 ans
pour tous
ce n'est que dans six mois environ que
l'on pourra vraiment lé établie dans
l'immédiat
vingt mille salariés ont demandé des
informations sur ce nouveau droit social
c'est le chiffre qu'il faut retenir donc
on voit bien avec cette enquête les
problèmes que se posent
valéry giscard d'estaing aux journées
d'étude des avocats le président de la
république a prononcé un discours
aujourd'hui souvent applaudi surtout
lorsqu'il a parlé de l'indépendance de
la défense qui est un des principes de
valeur constitutionnelle
lorsqu'il a aussi parlé du statut
libéral de l'avocat qui lui évite d'être
transformée peu à peu en fonctionnaires
mais at il ajouté c'est toute la justice
qui doit être indépendante à l'égard de
tous les pouvoirs comme l égard de
l'opinion monsieur giscard d'estaing a
évoqué le rapport du comité d'étude sur
la violence qui lui a été remis en
juillet alain peyrefitte qui présidait
ce comité
avant d'être nommé garde des sceaux a
été chargé de préparer rapidement la
mise en oeuvre des principales
recommandations contenues dans le
rapport les premiers textes seront
soumis au gouvernement avant la fin de
l'année enfin le président de la
république à traiter d'une critique
souvent fait à la justice elle est trop
lente
voici sa réponse
il ne s'agit pas que la justice devienne
expéditive
il ne s'agit pas que le jugement soit
bâclé la lenteur est souvent la
condition de la sérénité le scrupule est
souvent la condition de l'objectivité
les garanties dues à la personne et aux
intérêts du justiciable implique
inévitablement des délais supprimer ces
délais vous supprimez ces garanties
il demeure vis-à-vis du justiciable qui
défend ses intérêts du prévenu ou de
l'inculpé qui lutte pour son honneur et
sa liberté que des lenteurs non
indispensables sont contraires à
l'esprit de justice
c'est pourquoi tant au pénal qu'au civil
le gouvernement a cherché à faciliter
l'exercice d'une justice suffisamment
rapide au pénal l'exemplarité de la
sanction et le respect dû aux droits
individuels exige que les affaires
criminelles et délictuelles soient jugés
sans retard au civil une intervention
tardive de la décision judiciaire peut
réduire à néant l'intérêt pratique d'un
procès il faut lutter sans relâche
contre les risques d'encombrement qui
peuvent paralyser certaines juridictions
il faut réfléchir constamment au moyen
d'une authentique simplification par la
suppression de certains archaïsmes qui
freinent inutilement la procédure coupe
davis en finale de la zone européenne la
france affronte l'italie détentrice de
la coupe
les français très courageux part et ils
font mieux que se défendre pourtant
patrice dominguez a été battu par
l'italien panatta le match geoffrey
barazzutti interrompu par l'obscurité en
était à 2 partout pierre fulla
suspense sur le central surchauffé du
foro italico de rome il a fallu trois
heures trente de jeu pour savoir qui de
la france ou d'italie
kanata dominguez le gaucher s'est battu
et bien battu concédant cercle premier
set 6 4
mais réagissant au cours de la deuxième
manche qu'il remporte à 6,4 grâce à une
remarquable efficacité au filet
l'italien pu se détacher au troisième
set mais fatigué dû laisser l'avantagent
de la quatrième manche à dominguez 6 3
on crée alors le français capable de
créer une surprise mais andrienne
panatta su faire la différence grâce à
son meilleur service et s'imposa
finalement 5ème set 6-3 pour la plus
grande joie des tifosi déchaînés 1 0
pour l'italie c'est donc encore sur
françoise au frais ses 35 ans son
enthousiasme et sa détermination que
vont reposer tous les espoirs français
face aux jeunes barazutti la rencontre
interrompue en raison de l'obscurité a
déjà tenu toutes ses promesses
égalité deux sets partout demain
cinquième set tout est encore possible
avec françois jauffret
pardonner les lapsus l'italien s'était
barazzutti et le commentateur de ces
images c'était pire fut là demain le bol
d'or la plus grande épreuve motocycliste
en france une grande compétition
d'endurance puisqu'il s'agit des 24
heures du mans de la moto mais aussi un
grand pèlerinage pour les motards une
vraie fête patronne est d'ailleurs par
tf1 départ demain après midi à 16 heures
jean pierre chapel va vous parler
maintenant des essais le mans où nous
vivons déjà dans l'ambiance du bol d'or
dont ce sera demain la 41e édition
en effet depuis quatre à cet après-midi
se déroulent les essais chronométrés les
derniers avant la course de demain
cst vous permettent de déterminer la
place des coureurs dans la grille de
départ
mais vous savez comme le départ ce prix
dans le style le mans et que la course
durant plus de 24 heures
en fait la position dans la grille n'a
pas grande importance mais ces essais
par contre permettent une dernière mise
au point des machines et surtout aux
pilotes de vérifier dans quelle état et
leur machine et surtout comment vont
celle des concurrents et déjà il n'ya
plus tellement de surprises
les premiers on ne mettra ce que nous
avons nous indique déjà que les
meilleurs temps sont réalisées par deux
honda notamment celle de léon chemarin
qui sont les grands favoris ils ont
tourné en une 44 08 c'est à dire à la
moyenne de plus de 146 cris les
kilométreurs se dire plus vite que
l'année dernière
derrière il y a les kawasaki mais entre
les deux s'est intercalé la yamaha de
katayama le champion du monde en 350
donc voilà déjà comment se présente la
lutte bagarre entre honda et kawasaki
avec anne outsider possible
la yamaha de katayama mais rien n'est
joué encore la course va durer 24 heures
rendez vous demain sur les antennes de
tf1 ou si vous le pouvez venez ici
il fera beau et je voulais sur ce sera
une course superbe jean pierre chapel
tf1 le mans
v no son rendez vous jean pierre chapel
avoue jean claude narcy pour les autres
nouvelles de ce journal 83 % du budget
de la santé pour 1978 seront consacrés
aux aides pour les plus défavorisés pour
la prévention sanitaire et pour des
subventions à divers régimes de sécurité
sociale
simone veil en le présentant à la presse
a souligné qu'il s'agissait là d'un
budget de solidarité sociale
à la suite des déclarations faites hier
soir par monsieur georges marchais au
cours de l'émission de tf1 sur la
sidérurgie française jacques fery le
président de ce secteur de l'industrie a
déclaré que la sidérurgie française n'a
reçu de l'état aucune subvention ni don
de quelque nature que ce soit mais
exclusivement des prêts remboursables
avec intérêt enfin la sidérurgie n'a
procédé jusqu'en 1977 à aucun
licenciement et ses effectifs globaux
ont augmenté de 7000 personnes en dix
ans le conflit furnon c'est fini les 44
ouvrière cgt de l'entreprise acceptent
de reprendre le travail dès lundi matin
edgar faure renonce à se présenter à
paris pour les législatives le président
de l'assemblée nationale sera candidat à
pontarlier dans la troisième
circonscription du doubs aux élections
sénatoriales à paris c'est christian
dame allen qui conduira la liste unique
de la majorité sur la liste commune
socialistes radicaux de gauche on note
la candidature de georges dayan un mythe
françois mitterrand et chez les
communistes la liste est conduite par le
sénateur sortant serge bush ni un
général russe aux manoeuvres de l'otan
ce n'est pas fréquent et pourtant le
général kir kof a bien suivi les
manoeuvres qui se sont déroulés en
allemagne de l'ouest
c'est que bones avait invité toutes les
nations signataires de l'accord
d'helsinki de 1975
ces manoeuvres ont mobilisé quelque
trente mille soldats venus des états
unis et d'allemagne de l'ouest bien
longtemps
dans le conflit de l'ogaden qui oppose
les combattants du front de libération
de la somalie occidental à l'ethiopie la
base de jjg à une importante station de
tanks éthiopien est tombée aux mains des
combattants du front de libération plus
de 50 chars ont été détruits ainsi que
dix avions de combat à faire des tueurs
de l'ardèche de nouvelles inculpations
un couple qui avait hébergé conti un de
ses complices a été inculpé de recel de
malfaiteurs pour les policiers l'
enquête progresse et le filet se
resserre sur les fuyards deux parieurs
du vaucluse sont les heureux gagnants du
quarté pour trois francs
puis ils ont empoché chacun 284 1848
francs 50 soit plus de 28 millions de
centimes tiercé dimanche dans le prix
vermeille épreuves classiques pour les
pouliches de 3 ans sur 2400 mètres andré
théron choisi parmi les 18 concurrents
le 12 trillions leucate busacca et le
xviii fabuleux jack
enfin ce soir sur tf1 à 22h10 le numéro
un du nouveau magazine du football
téléfoot un chacun vendredi chaque
vendredi soir pierre cangioni présentera
les meilleurs moments des rencontres de
football française et internationale
donc ce soir à 22h10 téléfoot 1 et
première édition le temps et bien
aujourd'hui la tenait température était
plutôt en baisse sur la plupart des
régions seules près de la méditerranée
dans le sud ouest on a bénéficié de
températures plus clémentes demain sur
l'ensemble de la france matinée sera
assez brumeux soit avec des nuages bas
soit avec des brouillards
mais on pourra observer également des
éclaircies locale au cours de la journée
ces formations brumeuses disparaîtront
pour faire place à des éclaircies et des
nuages ces derniers seront plus
développé près des frontières du nord
ainsi que sur le nord-est et sur le nord
des alpes ou quelques averses sont
probables l'après midi
en revanche les éclaircies seront plus
nombreuses près de l'atlantique et de la
méditerranée
températures en baisse et le même type
de temps persistera dimanche maria
callas celle que l'on appelait la diva
celle que l'on a considéré comme l'une
des plus grandes tragédiennes lyrique de
son temps est morte au début de l'après
midi
victime d'une crise cardiaque elle était
âgée de 54 ans elle n'était pas apparu
sur une scène depuis 1973
maria callas fille d'un pharmacien
grecque installée à new york s'est très
vite
révélé comme une nature pratiquement
unique dans l'histoire de l'opéra on a
parlé à son sujet de phénomène vocal de
génie du théâtre son ex mari
l'industriel italien meneghini qu'elle
avait quittée en 59 a déclaré tout à
l'heure un personnage aussi grand ne
devaient pas mourir je suis désespéré
mais surtout la callas devint très vite
un mythe
sa liaison avec l'armateur grec onassis
a défrayé la chronique pendant dix ans
mais c'est finalement une rivale
inattendue qui épousa onassis
jackie kennedy la veuve du président
assassiné depuis c'était dans 68 maria
callas éviter les mondanités
elle avait créé une école de chant à new
york et vivait la plupart du temps dans
son appartement parisien
la dernière fois qu'elle a chanté la
norme à paris elle reconnaissait que sa
carrière de star ne représentait pas que
des avantages
et que le champ tout cas exigeait une
discipline de fer extrait d'un reportage
réalisé à l'opéra depuis mon enfance
j'ai l'air très très costaud et je ne le
suis pas et laurent suit la carrière qui
était très dur et très belle tout d
énervement toutes les choses est
évidemment un physique ne peut pas tenir
le coup toujours je suis une femme quand
même travailler c'est pas à 8 heures par
jour c'est travailler souvent même fait
par jour les quatre de sommeil compenser
les subventions qu'au travail
oh oh oh
voilà c'était notre adieu à la callas
sur ces très belles images
beaucoup de tous ceux qui aiment la
musique retraiterons la casse dernier
journal jean pierre pernaut vers 23h15
merci de votre attention